let's see I'm going to kill some lights
here so that
for her okay fine okay I'm gonna kill
some lights here if I could remember how
to do this okay now usually if I do this
in one of my classes within five minutes
half the students are asleep but I
promise not to try to put you to sleep
on this one now now this I was actually
asked to do this in light of some of the
recent events that have happened just in
the last few months I mean we're only in
May of 2010 and there have already been
some some interesting major disasters
now this actually this photograph here
behind the this in the title is actually
from Iceland actually not even from all
that long ago and will actually talk a
bit about Iceland and some of the other
recent events in fact right now just to
sort of open things up now Iceland's
eruption recent eruption that as as far
as anybody knows is sort of died off
just as of a few days ago and flights to
Europe have started to continue it it's
actually one of these sort of you know
or most unusual volcanic events that
wind up causing as we already know sort
of a major disaster in terms of air
travel to Europe economic troubles for
Europe and probably further economic
problems for Iceland which is already
suffering from the latest economic
collapse the this has got this funny
name to it that nobody can ever
pronounce so I'm gonna give it a shot
here which is a F yalla yalla okay and
AF yalla is actually the name of the
volcano yo coal is a glacier that it
actually sits underneath so a lot of
times you're seeing it in the news is a
yalla local volcano but it's actually
the hala volcano itself even before that
we also saw these devastating
earthquakes in Haiti which was about a
magnitude 7.0 in January and then
followed not that long afterwards by
this really big earthquake in Chile the
one in Haiti was when you look at the
magnitude now magnitudes are usually
what they're called logarithmic you know
you go up by one that means you go up by
a factor of 10 and size factor of 30 and
energy and the Haiti earthquake is about
500 times less powerful than the one in
Chile but wound up causing many many
more deaths over 200,000 deaths in Haiti
whereas
or maybe 500 as of last count in Chile
alone okay so it doesn't always have to
do with the size of the earthquake that
winds up causing the most amount of
devastation now what we're gonna sort of
talk about is whether or not these
things are unusual and so one of the
questions I've often had just in fact
following the Chile earthquake is from a
student not from one of my classes but
from a student elsewhere that asked
whether or not these are related whether
or not the Haiti earthquake caused a
Chile earthquake and whatnot and in fact
at the time that I was even asked to
give this lecture this is before the
Iceland eruption even happen so so it's
a lucky thing that I decided to talk
about volcanoes today as well but one of
the points one of the questions is
whether or not 2010 is extraordinary the
answer is no okay
I mean I hate to disappoint anybody to
think that maybe this year is special
but is it really because these events
well earthquakes and volcanoes happen
all the time okay and in fact this
diagram that you're seeing here sort of
a crude diagram is actually I just
downloaded it from the unit US
Geological Survey today about an hour
ago this shows what earthquakes have
occurred in the last seven days alone
okay and in fact this earthquake here
was in the Northern Mariana Islands
about two hours ago
okay which when I downloaded this so red
means about an hour ago just before I
left home okay
there was about a 7.2 followed by other
aftershocks this blue means actually
just about a day ago but just the brown
Thursday there was a pretty big one in
Vanuatu which is down here okay and you
can see these earthquakes occurring all
over the place okay Chile continues to
have aftershocks and reverberations even
months later okay
so again that's just from today and if
anybody wants that website you're more
than welcome to it now one of the things
that we want to talk about today is a
bit of the science that goes behind this
and I'm not going to go into all of the
gory detail in fact I'm only going to
talk about earthquakes and volcanoes I
teach a class called natural disasters
and we do everything from hurricanes
climate change meteorite impacts and
earthquakes and volcanoes okay but I'm
not going to do everything all right so
first of all are some things I want to
relay without going into you know
lots and lots of gory detail is it's
just the concepts that allow us to say
something about where we know these
events to occur and what's the nature of
these events okay that while they're not
individually predictable we can
certainly learn a lot and have learned a
lot to be able to say where you should
avoid living what type of building
standards you should have that are very
rarely met especially in developing
countries and so what we'll go through
is first of all talk about why we have
these at all what's the fuel for these
natural disasters that the earth is
mobile obviously it's in bulb Isle we
see volcanoes and earthquakes occurring
all the time
plate tectonics is really the basic
concept that sometimes called a grand
unifying theory of earth science okay
and it explains almost everything and if
we know something about that
then we can know a lot about earthquakes
and volcanoes where they occur and what
kinds they're going to be so why
earthquakes are not the same same with
volcanoes and then we'll ramp it up
okay and so we have quite a bit of
material to go through but now I often
begin my classes talking about the
beginning of the universe itself which
is relevant but since I only have an
hour I'm going to skip the first 10
billion years and jump straight to the
last 5 billion years which I'll do in
one slide so about 5 billion years ago
we know that the solar system more or
less came together and the earth
accreted and in fact that process is
pretty fast it only takes place over a
few you know tens of millions of years
to form a planet and in fact they come
together by just sort of the glomming
together in collisions of rocks and dust
particles through various stages and we
won't have to go into all that but the
most important point from this is that
all the energy from the collisions that
happens from these planets coming
together winds up being deposited inside
our planet as heat just because you know
you know that you've often seen movies
when a meteorite this is a huge one of
course but anything winds up hitting the
earth it winds up hitting with so much
energy wins the big knighting oxygen and
the rocks and stuff like that and wines
are putting out a lot of heat that gets
buried inside the earth and this is a
form of he called primordial heat
meaning ancient heat that's still inside
the earth and the basic point is that
the earth is still cooling to space it's
a big planet and it's rocky and it moves
very very slowly and it takes a
long time for it to cool off the space
and it's gonna take another you know
several you know maybe ten billion years
before it loses all its heat so all that
heat that was stored from those
collisions is actually eventually
cooling off to the colder space so the
earth is actually putting out through
the surface about 40 terawatts night I'm
not gonna actually throw numbers around
too much in this talk but this is just
to give you an idea you know you've got
a 100 watt light bulb okay 40 terra
watts is 40 trillion watts okay so
that's a trillion 40 watt light bulbs
okay that's spread more or less around
the earth sort of okay it's actually
coming up in various spots here and
there it also is being generated by
decay of elements like uranium and
thorium so it's about half and half
about half of its coming from what was
stored from collisions about half from
the decay of these elements this is the
fuel for geologic hazards now you might
think that number is big but what is it
that we receive from the Sun okay every
day we get about a hundred and seventy
thousand terawatts about okay four
thousand times the amount of energy
comes to us from the Sun as is leaking
out from the inside of the earth and
this actually goes quite far in
explaining why hurricanes happen every
season and hurricanes in fact are far
more damaging in terms of just total net
damage because earthquakes will happen
every ten hundred years or so in a given
spot okay but hurricanes happen
I'm sorry earthquakes will happen not
that often the Hurricanes of course will
happen about every year and cause a lot
of damage so this actually goes quite
far in explaining it
just in terms of the fuel that actually
powers these things but I'm not going to
go into hurricanes other than just a
grazes point now one that last thing is
you may think this forty trillion watts
is big but to give you a sense of it if
I were to take that power output and I
was to you know put it as light bulbs
okay hundred watt light bulbs all over
the surface of the earth okay I just
distributed evenly it would be about two
light bulbs per football field okay it's
not much it would barely light up it
wouldn't even light up a stadium you
couldn't read by it okay so that's not
as much as you think but it's enough to
power these geological disasters so what
actually makes things move if things are
cooling off that's fine
okay but what makes a move is convection
I mean convection is something that I
spend a lot of time studying it's one of
those very basic ideas that drives
the Earth's interior the atmosphere the
Sun the oceans all the stuff so it's one
of these Universal concepts and it's not
hard to understand it's that hot stuff
goes up and the cold stuff goes down
okay
hot stuff is light cold stuff's heavy
okay the hot stuff Rises the cold stuff
Falls that's all you have to really all
you need to know well this also happens
to occur in the mantle now you can get
an example of this by just looking at
your cup of coffee next time you have
one and put a little cream in it and
don't stir it okay eventually you'll see
the cup of coffee convecting because the
cold stuff on the surface is sinking if
you just leave it alone you'll
eventually see cool little polygons
forming in your cream I promise you it
will work don't stir it just pour it and
slowly let it sit you'll see little
shapes and stuff forming and that's
actually convection occurring now in the
Earth's mantle which is this about three
thousand kilometer is about 1,800 miles
thick layer of rock between the crust
and the core
okay the sort of reddish thing here is
it's solid rock a lot of times people
think it's molten that's the only way
you can move but it's not it's solid and
it's solid and moves in the same way
that glaciers move if that glass even
flows over long enough periods of time
okay and the stuff near the surface is
cold and it sinks the stuff near the
bottom is hot is heated up by the core
and it rises okay and then this whole
mantle convex ok very slowly this is
sort of a computer simulation showing
the blue stuff is cold going down sort
of you know dripping and flowing all
over the core the hot stuff is rising
and bobbing up which is the yellow stuff
now it moves very slowly so I have your
1 to 10 centimeters a year that doesn't
give you much of a concept of it but
it's about as fast as your fingernails
grow okay I know you can't sit there and
watch your fingernails grow okay well at
least I hope you're not doing it right
now all right okay but you know they
grow right so you know that it happens
or hair growth or things like that all
right so it's about as fast as your
fingernails grow
all right so plate tectonics plate
tectonics is the form of convection okay
in the mantle but that we see at the
surface okay and I'm going to go over
this in a little bit I'm going to try to
beat this into your head a little bit
because this is sort of one of the
underlying concepts to explain much
about earthquakes and volcanoes okay
which is that you have the earth is
divided up into plates but you've got
what's called big subduct subducting
slabs or these are
big tectonic plates that are the surface
cold part of the mantle that get cold as
they move away from where they first are
formed they get cold and they get cold
enough and they eventually sink into the
mantle okay
so again they're formed here where
they're hot they eventually move off say
this one moves off to the right it gets
cold enough eventually sinks that's a
form of this convection okay it's just
it's cold and heavy okay and as it winds
up sinking it winds up pulling these
plates behind it
sometimes ripping these plates open okay
so we're seeing this have been in
Iceland okay and there are various you
know there's some variations to this but
again I'll beat this into your head a
little bit so the most important part in
a way of understanding these things are
the types of boundaries we see from
plates now in a way we can focus mostly
on what's the big monster plate which is
the Pacific plate the Pacific plate
moves pretty fast it's about 10
centimeters a year which is one of the
fastest ones okay and it's diving off
here towards Japan and let's call the
corral trench okay and it's moving in
this direction where it's ramming in
towards Asia it's called convergence and
that's where things are subducting so
also subducting underneath Alaska and
the Aleutian trench so wherever we see a
deep-sea trench that's where the plates
are diving into the mantle like here
okay
where they are pulling apart okay are
called mid-ocean spreading centers okay
or mid-ocean ridges this is called the
East Pacific Rise off the coast of where
we are is the mid-atlantic rise where
the North American plane the Eurasian
Plate are pulling apart from each other
pretty slowly okay but the Pacific plate
is moving off in that direction it's
pulling apart from here which is called
a spreading Center or divergence ramming
into here where it's converging and on
the side it's quite the quite famous
what's called transform or strike-slip
fault where things are moving you know
side by side with each other is a San
Andreas Fault which is kind of a big
messy fault but it's one of the most
famous ones okay now here's a close-up
of what we can expect again I'm just
driving this into your head there's a
subduction zone again things dive into
the mantle spreading centers where
things pull apart transform faults
really slide by one another now the
nature of these different types of
boundaries tell us a lot about the kinds
of earthquakes and volcanoes that we'll
get okay so okay earthquakes and
volcanoes for
of all a curb almost exclusively not
entirely but but very much almost 90
more than 90% of them occur on plate
boundaries and this is actually a sort
of account okay a location of
earthquakes and volcanoes around the
globe and you'll see that they more or
less outline all the boundaries of the
plates okay there's some exceptions like
Hawaii here okay and a few others here
here and there okay and we'll talk about
those right let's see I've actually
wanted to go back one no that's okay
we're fine okay so what is an earthquake
okay an earthquake is where we have
plates on either side way off at a
distance are moving relative to each
other like a plate here is moving off in
the direction of that arrow and the
other one is moving differently so this
could be for example the Pacific plate
moving off to the north and the North
American plate moving or staying
stationary or moving south okay and they
pull and they pull and they pull and the
broq somewhere around here gets bent
okay where it's sort of vaguely weak and
eventually the stresses build up in it
that it winds up snapping and breaking
okay like it was if you were gonna take
a pencil and bend it and bend it and
bend it eventually will break okay
so eventually it will break and you
could take the pencil you know at a
distance and bend it and your fists
there are your hands that are bending it
but it's going to break somewhere in the
middle
once the they break and the blocks
basically rebound they basically bounced
you know one bounces for the other
bounces the other direction they wind up
moving rock okay ahead of it out of the
way and they wind up moving it very
rapidly and sending waves out sending
all types of seismic waves and I'm not
gonna go into the different kinds of
waves there are ones that are like sound
waves like you're hearing now and there
are waves that are like waves on a
string and the waves that are go like
waves on a string that go side to side
okay in the earth they wind up being the
most damaging with regard to buildings
because big tall buildings stand you
know high up sometimes it's a parking
garage underneath it and the wave going
side to side just take the legs out from
them from the building and it collapses
okay so one of the different types of
earthquakes of plate boundaries that we
can expect
okay there are spreading centers and
this is to give you a sort of a rule of
thumb about what we're going to look at
next and what we can expect from
different kinds of earthquakes and even
volcanoes spreading centers are
then they're hot they're weak they're
under tension pulling them apart okay
and I wind up getting small earthquakes
in fact so small that they're not
dangerous and no one really cares about
them transform faults this is sort of
you know all in one diagram the San
Andreas is a better example they're
moderately strong moderately cold okay
and they want about a moderate sized
earthquakes I always like to give my
students from California a hard time
because they complain about the number
of earthquakes in California it's rare
you get over a 7.0 people who live with
the 9.0 is like in Chile they have
something really worried about ok
subduction zones are those types well if
it's that the crust or the part of this
the earth is cold ok it's strong it's
under compression things are being
rammed together and when they break they
break in a big way ok they wind up
generating big earthquakes so where it's
hot you get not much where it's
intermediate you get moderate sized
earthquakes and where things are ramming
together they're cold thick and strong
you wind up getting big earthquakes ok
these are the monster earthquakes come
from so sort of quickly going over some
of these transform boundaries because in
the US this is particulars of course
California is the most populous state it
also happens to be sitting on one of the
most active boundaries okay on the
planet ok however over you know a
hundred or more years of earthquakes
California has developed excellent
building codes so even decent sized
earthquakes on the San Andreas and tend
not to cause an enormous amount of
damage and destruction like you often
see elsewhere so of course one of the
most famous earthquakes that's occurred
in in California on the San Andreas
Fault is the 1906 earthquake in San
Francisco which in a way was sort of the
birth of understanding seismology in
fact you know the Chinese and in times
BC which were actually studying
earthquakes and had rudimentary
seismometers okay but so so San
Francisco in 1906 was home for about
400,000 people nothing like it is today
there was an intense ground shaking the
amount of fatalities were not enormous
ok except for the fact that it was not a
huge population what actually caused
most of the damage ok and this is one of
those things that gives you a clue
building codes is that the is that gas
lines were broken which caused fires to
set be set off water lines were broken
which meant you couldn't put the fires
out so a lot of the destruction in San
Francisco was due to fires being set off
after that destruction presently the San
Andreas Fault it's a complicated messy
fault it's not one fault it's actually a
braided fault it's just has tons of them
but the San Andreas is the main one and
just to give you a sense of it the
president the the 1906 section is
currently locked meaning basically it's
locked up and it's very hard to move
which means it's actually prime for
possibly another earthquake there's an
area south of it that actually it's
called creeping it basically always has
a ton of little earthquakes on it and
has no trouble moving and then there's
these areas down here towards Los
Angeles San Bernardino which are locked
again and what happens is that when a
fault like this is bent it winds up
becoming difficult to move okay it
doesn't slide side by side a winds being
bent and gets jammed up and locked okay
so one of the more famous ones that if
it has occurred in California is of
course a Loma Prieta the world series
series earthquake since that occurred
during the World Series at the time that
was again not an enormous earthquake of
magnitude six point nine people remember
this because of the collapse of there
was really damage in two main areas a
Marina District and in this interstate
880 was there several layers of the of
this freeway quand a pancake you're
collapsing onto each other and about 40
people or so were killed and this is
interesting in fact that the where the
most of the damage occurred was where a
lot of these structures were built on on
soft sediments and in fact rubble left
over from the 1906 earthquake so what
happened in these areas although
building codes elsewhere are pretty good
when the earthquake happened these areas
shook because they were sitting on soft
rubble II you know muds and sediments an
example that's often raised as something
that might possibly happen in Los
Angeles people often worry in Los
Angeles about the thing called the Big
Bend which is that lock'd zone that I
showed you around San Bernardino is the
the Kobe earthquake okay in 1995 on the
nojima fault this was sort of one of
these spectacular photographs where this
entire freeway got tipped over to a
sign again it's about a 7.0 earthquake
with a bunch of you know aftershocks but
again this wind up actually causing a
significant number of fatalities due to
building codes that were not quite ready
for this and obviously including
building of freeways okay
Haiti is of course one that we most are
concerned with most recently because of
course it just happened a few months ago
and people want to know more about it
and it's actually quite an interesting
earthquake
first of all Haiti and in fact the whole
island of Hispaniola so there is a
Dominican Republic connected to it it
actually sits on the boundary of the
Caribbean plate okay it's a little tiny
plate like what course it's off in the
Caribbean and the Caribbean plate is
sort of moving off well it's actually
the Atlantic is moving to the west but
it's abducts right underneath here and
we're gonna come back to these and look
at volcanoes on this side of the Eastern
Caribbean later but right along here you
can see the plates move side to side and
a close-up of it
shows that there are two main faults
that bound the island of Hispaniola and
Haiti and port-au-prince is right around
here okay there is the enric Hilo fault
in the Septon tree onal fault
okay up here and these are both again
strikes the faults like the San Andreas
much smaller okay and as we all know on
January the 12th or occurred the 7.0
earthquake which unfortunately occurred
only about 10 miles away from
port-au-prince okay which is actually
one of the reasons that caused a lot of
damage but what also caused a lot of
damage is the fact that there were very
poor building codes okay for an
earthquake that was not enormous okay it
wind up causing over 200 thousand deaths
in the end okay because of the fact that
there were just shoddy building codes
elsewhere and this often happens we find
when earthquakes occur in Turkey in
Pakistan okay that you have moderate
sized earthquakes that wind up causing a
lot of fatalities mostly because of poor
construction or preparation beforehand
so this is a before-and-after of the
presidential palace okay streets of
port-au-prince that were of course
decimated by this now one of the the
things to be aware of and certainly the
government in Haiti and and and
reparation efforts have to be aware of
is the likelihood of another earthquake
occurring there there is a you know in
terms of predicting earthquakes there's
a thing called
iseman gap theory which basically says
if I have a big earthquake here but a
dearth of earthquakes on the same fault
it probably means they're stress
building up where there's not enough
earthquakes you have a lot of little
earthquake it's it's a good thing but if
you have a big earthquake but then it
winds a building stress up on this fault
it's likely that another earthquake will
occur there and in fact it is likely
that another earthquake will occur on
the Unruh kilo fault in this area on
Hispaniola probably within the next at
least for the next hundred years which
is about as good a prediction as you can
get it may happen sooner okay and this
is actually a prediction of the stress
build up on that area okay so let's move
on and talk about subduction zone
earthquakes
these are the big monsters okay
subduction zone earthquakes again I'll
remind you this is where the whole
strong cold part of the upper part of
the earth is cold strong it's being
rammed into a continent usually okay so
there's collision zones and it's very
hard for it to bend and break and when
it does it breaks in a big way and this
is when you wind up getting these
monster earthquakes like the one that
happened in Chile not that long ago
Chile in fact is known for not that far
from the one that happened recently is
known for having the biggest recorded
earthquake of a 9.5 ok 9.5 is uh Norma's
okay so the 8.8 that happened a while
ago that's almost a whole factor of 10
weaker not quite maybe a factor of seven
weaker okay than the one that happened
in 1960 and the Sumatra on-demand
earthquake also occurred then so to
remind you most of these earthquakes
occur around the Pacific plate the
Pacific plates moving this direction you
have the Aleutians all through here in
Japan okay this is where a lot of the
earthquakes these big earthquakes occur
but over here and Chile is where another
plate which is not shown it's called the
Nazca plate diving it up against or
ramming up against South America and you
get those here too and this is often
called the Ring of Fire many times
you've seen a reference to the thing
called the Ring of Fire
these are actually surround all the
subduction zones that go around the
earth except of course a San Andreas
right here so all along the Pacific this
is where the Nazca plate dives up and
rams up against South America now when a
subduction zone earthquake happens it's
a little different than what happens in
a transform fault but the similar idea
that as I have this slab trying to sink
into the mantle the
crust above it winds up being locked on
this blue zone and bending almost like
if you were imagining a crossbow or a
bow and arrow okay if I was bending this
big plate bending it down eventually the
stress is built up enough that a nun
bends and pops up okay and when it pops
up of course it causes an enormous
earthquake but it can also wind up
generating tsunamis so here's a little
example the dashed line here is before
it pops up afterwards it pops up and
hoists this big mound of water out up
that winds up sending tsunamis out it's
like you know ripples in a pond but very
very very big ripples okay so some
examples of this are classic ones like
in Alaska in 1946 there was about a 9.2
earthquake which I listed before and it
wound up generating an enormous tsunami
and to give you a sense of the power of
it this is a basically a solid cement
lighthouse a scotch gap in the Aleutian
Islands before and after basically after
there is nothing okay there were several
workers in the lighthouse that were
killed from about a 30 something 30
meter which is about a hundred feet high
tsunami that immediately hit this
because it was there was no warning time
this probably hit within you know a
minute of the actual earthquake
occurring that wind up wiping out this
lighthouse entirely and then it
continued to move across the Pacific and
killed about 160 people in Hawaii from
the tsunami itself now from the
earthquake from the tsunami okay that
then continued to move on across the
Pacific okay we saw an example of this
when the Chile earthquake happened
people in Hawaii we're worried about it
tsunami hitting there as well this is
actually what you know an example of a
tsunami coming up on the ship on the on
the port of Hilo this is from Hilo
itself and a tsunami does not typically
look like some big giant breaking wave
that you might surf okay unless you're
an idiot
okay okay but it typically winds up
looking like a flood and this is a lot
of times why people have referred to in
the past as a tidal wave because it
looks like a rapidly rising tide has
nothing to do with tides okay but in the
background you can see this big bore big
white water rolling bore of water coming
up under the streets of Hilo and
everybody trying to get away from it
okay in 1960 there is this massive
earthquake that also wind up generating
a huge tsunami as well that wind up
rushing
across the Pacific by this time the
people in Hawaii were prepared there had
already started be the establishment of
warning centers but it also wound up
continuing on and killing about you know
almost 200 people in Japan itself so
again this was the biggest recorded
earthquake that's happened now this is
an example of again poor helo helo is in
a bit in a narrow bay so when the
tsunami hits it it winds up amplifying
the waves and helo got whacked again in
1916 you can see the power of this this
is you know knocking over you know from
that distance is knocking over a parking
meter okay and of course just a few
years ago there was this devastating
earthquake that occurred in Indonesia in
the couldn't that's called the Sumatra
Andaman Island earthquake that then
generated the Indian Ocean tsunami this
is a bizarre earthquake in that it was
very slow and it's probably it took
several years to figure out how big it
was the first estimates of it were
around 8 point something and eventually
it's been moved up to about a nine point
three it's possibly the second biggest
earthquake recorded okay so at the time
even from this slide it's thought people
thought it was a fourth largest but even
just within the last year so it's been
moved up it was a 1200 kilometre ripping
the earth that actually tore for seven
minutes which is one of the reasons why
it was hard to figure out how big it was
it wasn't like a big pop okay it was
actually a giant tear in the earth okay
and it happened about 30 kilometers at
depth which actually raised the seafloor
about 20 meters and generated this
enormous tsunami okay now this is a sort
of a movie or a calculation of what the
tsunami would have looked like as it was
racing across the Indian Ocean excuse me
and what's interesting of course is that
the deeper the water the faster these
things move so you actually will see
that this wave wound up hitting Sri
Lanka and India at about the same time
at at Thailand
now these waves move very fast okay they
move about as fast as a jet plane moves
they move about 500 miles an hour okay
when they're going across deep water as
they're going into shallow water they
move much more slowly but they also
learn to building up an amplitude okay
they wind up getting steeper as they go
to the shallower water especially coming
up onshore okay so this is an example
this is a Banda Aceh which is on the tip
of Sumatra this is a
for an after of this community that got
inundated by this hundred meter high
tsunami basically the whole community
was erased entirely since they're kids
in the audience I'm skipping over that
one and this just shows an example of
sometimes people are silly enough to
when it's tsunami comes sometimes the
wave doesn't come first the ocean draws
out and people think well all the
seafloor is exposed I'm gonna go out and
look at the fish and the clams and stuff
like that they're exposed them on this
and they literally do run out and a lot
of fatalities are due to that people
going out and looking at this exposed
seafloor and then the tsunami the wave
itself comes back in and they can't get
away in time a lot of times people here
at tsunamis coming I lived in Hawaii
before coming here for ten years
and when there were tsunami warnings
people used to rush down to like iki
Beach to see it coming which is not the
smartest thing you can do okay and a lot
of fatalities in the early tsunamis from
forty to nineteen forty six and sixty
were due to that so Chile and just
recently in February make sure I have
enough time to go over volcano so I'll
be almost done here Chile is located
over the subduction zone the Nazca plate
diving into again into the mantle
beneath South America the recent
earthquake occurred just off the coast
here in Santiago okay which is the
capital of Chile and it didn't occur it
occurred not that far away right so of
course the wind up causing enormous
damage but a surprising surprisingly few
fatalities about five hundred a little
over five hundred fatalities last count
this occurred about you know these are
just some numbers about two hundred
miles away from Santiago about seventy
miles away from concepción okay and in
fact this down here this big circle here
is the ninth the location of the 1960
earthquake okay
down here and this is the current one so
it didn't occurred that far away from
that monster earthquake that occurred in
1960 okay this is an example of sort of
the direction of the or this is really
like the wave amplitude the height of
the wave and the tsunami that was
generated by this and it wound up
sending these you know it doesn't just
come out as simple little ripples in a
pond because of the the shape of the
seafloor it winds up sometimes sending
out looks like almost like beams okay in
fact San Diego did get some damage okay
but this beam noticed just missed Hawaii
so
was on call and preparation for a big
tsunami to hit but it wound up missing
it okay but it did wind up causing
damage of course all the way down the
coast of Chile okay there were a tsunami
damage from this one earthquake just
recently so let's do volcanoes next okay
can we have a little time I love this
movie there's a great this website here
has some this is a photographer who
somehow manages to go around and film in
film and photograph volcanoes all over
the world and I've decided I want his
job okay okay so this is actually from
Montserrat and actually recently I took
a class from my natural disasters class
to the Caribbean and I'll show you some
photos of that and a little bit and the
in fact in between the time when I went
to scope out the islands we wanted to go
to and when we went back Montserrat
exploded in fact sort of eliminated our
chances of seeing Montserrat which I
hope to see we'll see more of that later
so like earthquakes volcanoes occur
mostly on plate boundaries okay not all
of them but most of them okay and the
magma the types of lava that comes up in
the eruption style depends a lot on that
type of plate boundary just as it is
with earthquakes okay so for example
mid-ocean ridges where things are
pulling apart okay it winds up drawing
mass up from the mantle okay this heavy
mantle okay and as it winds up drawing
this mass up the release of pressure
winds up allowing that stuff to melt
it's not that it gets hotter it's that
you wind up taking some pressure off
this stuff that's coming up and the
release of pressure causes this thing to
melt and it comes up into these
mid-ocean ridges and creates a lot of
volcanism okay that we just don't happen
to care about that much okay this mantle
rock is dense and it's full of fill of
metals okay metals like iron and
magnesium and some calcium and that sort
of heavy concentration of metals makes
that lava very runny very low viscosity
okay
what's called basaltic magma you've
probably heard the word basalt
okay so basaltic magma is very runny
alright on the seafloor mid-ocean ridges
since they're out on the bottom we don't
tend to see very much of them actually
most of the production of magma happens
at sea floors about 80 percent of it
actually happens at these mid-ocean
ridges okay but it just happens to come
out and
very slow losing fashion nothing
explosive it's very runny it just spills
out and wants us spilling on what's
called pillow basalts and sometimes you
can see movies of these pillow basalts
inflating like balloons okay they're not
explosive okay and so we didn't I won't
even mention them ever again
okay well maybe at another class I'll
mention them again but not to you okay
so there are non plate tectonic
volcanoes Hawaii is the classic example
which do not occur on plate boundaries
and they're worth mentioning this is
thought to be what's called a hot spot
or a intraplate volcano where there is a
hot spot in the mantle okay and there
are a lot of debates about what causes
these people like myself think they're
caused by a hot upwelling in the mantle
but sometimes called a mantle plume that
that rises up and eventually burns a
hole or melts a hole in the crust
remember the specific plate is moving
off here towards Japan and as it moves
off its beat it's a having a hole burnt
in it and you wind up developing this
island chain the whole state of Hawaii
is right here but the whole Hawaiian
chain goes all the way out here to
Midway then then because the plate was
moving to the north you know more than
50 million years ago
there's called the emperor chain that's
all part of the same hot spot okay so
it's called sometimes called the
Hawaiian Emperor seamount chain you get
all together
alright so these also wind up drawing
stuff up from the mantle it's the same
material okay it's metal rich and it
makes thin runny basaltic lava okay so
as an example here's me okay playing
with lava it's one of the favorite
things to do in Hawaii okay I'm taking a
poking this lava with a stick and you
can see it dripping and running okay it
is hot and painful to play with but okay
but it's worth it alright one of the
things you just got to try
so when lava comes out first it actually
has a lot of water in it or some water
when it first comes out at winds up
coming out and these look like they're
explosive but they're nothing compared
to the explosivity of the really big
earthquakes like st. Helens Mount
Pinatubo okay these only go up about
maybe a kilometer okay they look big but
they're not that big but they're
impressive because they're hot and
glowing okay so the gas comes out first
and it's blowing these things out and
what's called fire fountains and fire
curtains after the gas is all gone the
law of accont in use to spell out and
makes river
lava tubes lava lakes things like this
because it's very runny the types of
volcanoes it builds are called shield
volcanoes Mon Aloha is actually one of
the biggest volcanoes on the planet but
when you're standing on Hawaii looking
at it it doesn't look that impressive
okay but it is massive because it goes
all the way to the seafloor right so
that's a typical type of volcano you see
it's a shield volcano now to talk about
some events
just a little storytelling we'll talk
about a couple all right with regard to
Hawaii in particular and also Iceland so
during in 1790 there was actually a sort
of a freak eruption that wanted having a
big influence politically at the time
with regard to King Kamehameha's Wars of
unification King Kamehameha some of you
may know as the first King that Captain
Cook actually came across and kamehameha
actually used European mercenaries to
help him win the war of unification and
at the time he was fighting this king
kayla who was for dominance on the big
island and kayla was at an army marching
to meet Kamehameha's army but there was
a freak blast in Kilauea it will
actually wind up being due to water
building up inside of a crater and the
water superheated and exploded and wind
up wiping out most of Kayla's army in
this sort of blast of ash and gas not so
dissimilar to what's happening in Hawaii
in in Iceland now but over you know
months as opposed to one freak blast
this actually wind up tipping the scales
and kamehame his favor and he went on to
continue to be the king of all the
Hawaiian Islands okay and if you go to
Hawaii in theory there are still
footprints from these soldiers in the in
the cows eart okay when I moved to
Hawaii I was like I mentioned I was a
professor there and I've moved as a
young assistant professor in 1990 well
pretty young and at the time we're
moving there was a flows coming from
Kilauea that were inundating the
community of Kalapana Kalapana was an
actual not a huge community but a
community with a golf course
at one time a golf course and this lava
from the kappa haaha eruption on it
flowing down and running over call upon
and it continues to run over kalapana
even - even today so this is actually
flow going literally over a a park okay
and at that time this is just to show
you how fast these areas fill up with
lava
this is a little mom-and-pop shop in
April of 1990 okay before the inundation
by June okay most of the building was
gone okay so the roof had been taken off
so it's probably up to about this level
okay and just a week later just one week
later Bulava had filled up to the base
of this sign okay all right so these are
some USGS guys standing out there so
this is the same sign as here all right
again I took a class in 2008 to Hawaii
and we went out to the kalapana flows
and this is what I you saw the picture
of me sticking the sticking the the lava
with a stick this is about when we went
to it so this is a Yale class staring at
some burning lava and it was a it was
impressive because there were you can
see the steam coming from here there is
live lava flowing under this I had to
remind our students when you see a crack
in the lava please don't all gather up
over the top of it okay it's not gonna
hold you
they were so enthralled with this but
somebody's shoes actually melted only
one okay and in Kalapana today is now
famous for its ocean entry this is
actually a photo from arc trip but you
continue to see a lava pouring into the
sea and it creates these gases actually
are more than just steam is actually
creating hydrochloric gas because it's
of course it's got salt that winds up
being superheated and wind up forming
hydrochloric cloud so you definitely
don't want to breathe so AF yella yokel
the one that just we think ended a
little while ago I'll mention a bit of
this so we've all seen quite a bit in
the news about this Iceland is a funny
volcano it's both a hotspot and at a
mid-ocean ridge this is where the North
Atlantic plate in the Eurasian Plate are
pulling apart from each other okay so
you actually get volcanism all the way
along this Ridge but it's also a hot
spot in the mantle that actually makes
this anomalous layer unusually hot and
and that's what actually causes it to be
sort of a little a big island okay so in
when the eruption
excuse me first started in March it was
actually
so when I started in March it was
actually typical of these types of runny
lavas that would occur and you wind up
causing fissure eruptions which you also
see in Hawaii this lava pouring out you
can see it sort of flooding the plains
here okay
the there were some local evacuations
this is not generally considered a very
dangerous type of eruption other than if
it winds up melting glacial waters and
causing floods
which in Iceland are called Yoko lumps
okay and those sometimes can be very
damaging but what was really most
damaging is when it entered the second
phase of explosive eruption which was
sort of unusual from about 8 April 14th
to about now okay it's still sort of
rumbling along the water from the
glaciers wound up flowing back into the
crater superheating and it's actually
the water that ones of driving the
explosion it also wanted some cooling
the magma and creating very small glass
particles that wind up getting lofted
into this eruption to create this ash so
it's actually this ash is made of of a
lot of very fine scale basalt glassy
particles which is of course one of the
reasons you don't want to fly into it in
an airplane we don't want to fly into
any volcanic ash in the airplane because
it completely will choke up the engines
so again it's mostly due to glacial
waters flowing in and not so dissimilar
from that erupt that freak eruption that
wind up giving some favor to King
Kamehameha in 1790 okay a water driven
eruption there's a name for it it's
called the phreatic eruption and these
often occur okay this eruption happened
to a loft about nine kilometres up into
the atmosphere which is quite high okay
but it just so happened that the jet
stream goes right over Iceland okay so I
wind up ejecting this ash directly into
the jet stream which wound up dragging
it all the way over to northern Europe
so this here is a satellite image okay
of the ash being dragged across the
North Atlantic towards the European
coast okay so it was a bad combination
of things of this having occurred under
a glacier where the Glacial water caused
explosions and happened to be sitting
right underneath the jet stream which
then dragged it off to northern Europe
okay what about what what worries
geophysicist and volcanologists is not
so much this one but is the much bigger
volcano
is right next story to it AFV Allah is
this little glacier right here right
next to it is this big glacier in a much
more massive volcano called Cutler and
Kotla has historically exploded
following the fe ala eruptions in the
past may fe allah has erupted before
like 1823 okay it erupted and caught
erupted in the big way right after that
so the big concern that Iceland and
Northern Europe have to prepare for is
that Kotla is actually quite likely to
blow in the possibly near future
probably within the next few years okay
so this is this is something that's
quite important okay so let me move on
to talk about finally about subduction
zones okay volcanism which are the big
monster types of volcanoes these are the
most violent and the most deadly of all
volcanoes and they again occur at
subduction zones so notice the recurring
theme the subduction zones where the
cold stuff sinks into the mantle is
where there are the biggest earthquakes
and they also happen to have the biggest
volcanoes okay so what happens this is a
little more complicated and just pulling
stuff up from the mantle and having it
melts okay that's that's easy relative
for Hawaiian and mid-ocean ridges and
Iceland okay for subduction zones what
happens is that you've got seafloor
sediments and crust that are loaded with
water they get dragged down into the
mantle and the hot mantle cooks the
water out okay right around here and the
water winds up seeping into this hot
mantle rock and because that mantle Rock
gets wet it melts once you wet make
something wet it actually melts more
easily that melt then percolates up
through the crust and on the way up it
winds up being contaminated reacting if
you want with crustal rock which is rich
in silica
now when I say silica that's things like
glass okay sand okay quartz that's pure
silica okay so I mix it with things like
that and I will wind up getting more
buoyant rock and lavas made from that
rock are very sludgy okay so when I take
that melted mantle and I contaminate it
with silica rich crustal rock by the
time it comes up it creates these
volcanoes but that type of lava tends to
be very very sticky and pasty and it
winds up creating these sticky lava
domes okay here if it's a little less
silica rich it winds up creating things
like Montserrat these don't flow nearly
as fast as Hawaiian lavas
okay but they kind of tumble and roll
okay but the really gooey sticky ones
will just wind up losing out and forming
these lava domes until they explode but
since they are loaded with water
remember I said they're caused by all
this water being cooked off okay because
they're loaded with water bubbles come
out and the bubble pressure the gas
pressure builds and builds okay until
it's actually able to unplug and break
and pop open these volcanoes and when it
does the pressures are so huge it
explodes in a big way most of the time
okay so the types of explosive eruptions
you see are called volcanion which are
just brief burps okay they shoot up
pretty high the plenty RUP shion's are
the big monster eruptions they continue
for hours and sometimes you know a day
or more okay and then calderas are
really enormous but rare after these
plenty interruptions empty out the magma
chamber you got this big empty hole in
the ground and it collapses and winds up
spewing out even more magma okay and so
you get you know various you know
calderas that occur but they're pretty
rare okay now let's just focus on these
plenty interruptions these plenty
interruptions are named after Pliny the
Younger who end up observing Mount
Vesuvius which I'll mention in a minute
again they're driven by gas bubbles
coming out and spewing and basically
popping open the volcano and spewing out
all this hot ash everywhere
did they do not come out and so using
lavas they come out in these massive gay
plumes of ash
okay hot ash these ashes these ash you
know ejecta wind up going 10 sometimes
even almost 50 kilometers up into the
atmosphere they want of shooting
particles up into the stratosphere that
wind up sometimes causing changes in
climate
in fact after Pinatubo there was a
distinct drop in global temperatures and
this is Mount Pinatubo okay in 1991
okay this shot up about 20 kilometers up
into the atmosphere this is one from the
Aleutian Islands that shoots up so high
it actually also sends a shockwave out
that pushes away the clouds around it
okay what happens after these you've got
these giant plenty eruptions eventually
this ash cools off and collapses
sometimes the eruption doesn't go
straight up it just comes straight out
the side but this is an example of fact
Pinatubo after this giant column of ash
often collapse it creates a thing called
pyroclastic flow pyro meaning fire
plastic meaning broken shards okay and
so you got these almost avalanches a
very very hot ash that wind up wiping
down onto the ground and traveling very
very fast you know somewhere around 300
kilometres an hour okay
so here's an example Pinatubo there's no
way that truck is going more than 300
kilometers an hour okay
so another that that's one of the bigger
dangers okay one of the things that
causes massive destruction are these
pyroclastic flows another one are lahars
lahars are when these the the hot ash
mixes with water or melts glacial waters
and creates this pasty mix of ash and
water that's almost like cement but
coming down steep slopes okay you've
seen when you pour cement Deportes very
quickly but once it settles it sort of
settles and becomes hard well it's a
similar thing happens here it flows very
quickly sometimes 50 kilometres an hour
okay and it can wind up over running you
know areas obviously you know
communities that sometimes are built up
in near rivers and in 1985 there is this
one of the biggest volcanic disasters
about 20,000 people were killed on
Nevado del Ruiz in Colombia from this
lahar this you know this flood of cement
ash mix that wound up burying this
entire village is very few buildings
left afterwards some classic structures
you will see from these types of
explosive volcanoes are called
stratovolcanoes for reaching up very
high very Fuji is a classic one this is
Mount st. Helens before it exploded
Mount Mayon there these are some of the
more very very typical classical shapes
of volcanoes so let's talk about a few
events and then we'll probably be close
to done so first of all the most famous
one of course is the destruction of
Pompeii by the eruption of Vesuvius in
79 k ad C D and in this particular case
the eruption wound up destroying Pompeii
by a pyroclastic flow now a lot of times
the image is that that Pompeii had many
many people in an effect the truth is
they had a pretty good idea that this
was going to erupt and they did evacuate
most of Pompeii one of the reasons
archaeologists find so few bodies in
Pompeii is that most of the city was
evacuated so it wasn't nearly as
disaster in terms of loss of life as is
often portrayed Herculaneum the nearby
city was also destroyed by a lahar that
followed afterwards and pump Pompeii
I mean Vesuvius has continued to be
active you know for hundreds of years
afterwards and one of the bigger
disasters was about you know in about 69
1630 about four thousand people were
killed in yet another eruption of
Vesuvius one of the biggest disasters in
history with regard to volcanic
destruction was Tambora the destruction
of Tambora which is in indonesia here
okay so here's Australia ten boroughs
right around here okay so Tambora wind
up having several massive plenty
eruptions that shot 43 kilometers high
into the atmosphere is you know just
have you an idea that the top of the
Trop of tropi pause where the cloud deck
is about 10 kilometers okay so it's way
up into the atmosphere okay and there
were several of these and the
pyroclastic flows wind up killing about
ten thousand and wiped out two kingdoms
of sangar and Tambora okay the
pyroclastic fault floes wound up wiping
out crops that wind up killing another
hundred thousand from famine and the
Plenty and eruptions wind up causing
global cooling and it's rather famous as
a year without a summer of 1816 okay so
this is actually a recent image of
Tambora itself and this is timber it's
quite a saintly volcano Krakatoa in
Indonesia is another classic example of
one in which there was an eruption and
then collapse the whole island into the
caldera okay that wind up again you know
killing a large number of people the
pyroclastic flows actually wound up
traveling so this is crack a towel in
the Sunda Strait between Sumatra okay
okay and in Jakarta okay and so the I'm
sorry Java and and so the pyroclastic
flow actually wound up traveling across
the Sunda Strait and wound up killing
about 2,000 people just on the coast of
Sumatra the resulting tsunami that wound
up hitting Java and Sumatra I wound up
reaching 35 meters over a hundred feet
hike killing another 36,000 people okay
so these things can be massive and what
they wind up generating you know not
just pyroclastic flows but by this
collapse of this island one
generating a tsunami that wind up
causing even more destruction Caribbean
volcanoes are one I'm going to bring up
because we were just there recently and
they're fascinating and it's got one of
the best volcanic stories around which I
have to tell quickly so the Caribbean of
course is we all know where the
Caribbean is just south of here and many
of you have vacationed there of course
not sure how many of vacation and
Martinique but Martinique is one of the
sites of one of the most famous and
deadly eruptions which is the eruption
of Pele Pele in fact is named after the
Hawaiian God Pele which is ironic
because Pele in lavas are actually court
or Hawaiian lavas are not very deadly
but mal Pele erupted in 1902 and one of
the fascinating stories about this is
that it you know it's it's famous for
having wiped out the town of Sint Pierre
but st. Pierre in fact knew about this
eruption in fact the indications of this
eruption were happening at least a month
ahead of time but what's famous about is
sort of the political stupidity that the
governor of Martinique insisted that
there'd be no evacuations of st. Pierre
because there was a very close election
going on between sort of the radical
party and a party of sort of white
plantation owners and he was worried
about losing power and wouldn't let
anybody evacuate from there meanwhile
the city was being inundated by ash
there was a destruction of a sugar
factory by a lahar by a mud flow at one
point the ash flow went of driving
snakes out of the woods called pit
vipers or faire des lots that invaded
the city wound up killing people so the
city itself was invaded by snakes and
the crazy story is that feral cats from
the city came storming out into the into
the town and battled the snakes and wind
up killing the snakes along with a
soldier so it's a crazy sort of
apocalyptic vision of what happened and
then around around May 8th the eruption
itself occurred and in this particular
case the blast was out of the side of
the crater itself it didn't go straight
up became shot directly out of the side
of the top of the crater a little lake
called it's on sec that why not be
heading directly for st. Pierre st.
Pierre was hit within a minute of these
of this hot ash cloud that literally
nuked the city I mean it looks this is
what the city look like it used to be a
big thriving city
the town was obliterated down to the
stumps okay of this and thirty thousand
people were killed largely because
people were also there was a propaganda
that Saint Pierre was safer than
elsewhere in the vicinity sofa
surrounding villages came in de st.
Pierre populations from surrounding
villages came into st. Pierre for safety
so actually swell the population before
it was wiped out there are only two
survivors now and one of them was a
prisoner who was sort of locked up in
the bottom of a cell there's a myth that
he was a murderer but it's probably not
true it was probably there for like
petty theft but he wanted getting a job
for Barnum & Bailey which then had this
to pump up the story made it sound like
he was someone on death row getting
ready to be executed and then this
eruption occurred so a lot of the
history has been mangled by Barnum and
Bailey this is actually an image of when
we were just there a couple of months
ago Montpellier in the background of
what a state pier today these are still
ruins of st. Pierre and we actually
marched up and drin and hiked up to the
peak of st. Pierre and there's a dome
inside this that you can't see from here
it's often covered in clouds but there's
an extra dome inside there which is
itself a pretty big mountain that was
literally built in about three years
yeah it's amazing thing to walk on a
mountain that was built in three years
and from 1902 to 1905 Montserrat is the
most active of Caribbean volcanoes and
it has been erupting since 1995 okay and
this is a little flow that comes down
it's a great picture of this sort of
tumbling flow that winds up incinerating
everything around and sending off this
get this this burning ash and in fact as
I mentioned in January this is when
these eruptions started to occur is when
the last eruption happened in between
our two trips there then there is
Dominica which is one of the islands we
went to Dominica is probably the site of
the most likely future disasters in the
Caribbean in fact when people look at
hazard assessments of the Caribbean
Dominica is always considered number one
of future hazards whereas most volcanoes
in the Caribbean have one volcano each
like Martinique as Montpellier ok one
active volcano Dominica has nine okay
has nine active volcano is a lot of them
in the south part of the island okay
we were here this is our trip hiking
here what's called a valley of
desolation in the boiling lake and it
really this is the valley of desolation
there's boiling mud pits behind it and
there is a whole lake that literally is
boiling I mean really boiling okay and
this is Scott's head which is actually a
failed crater which is a beautiful place
to dive in which is right here on the
tip okay and finally my last volcano of
course is is not st. Helens ok Mount st.
Helens within sort of us volcanoes is
probably one of the most famous ones 19
the 1980 eruption and I happened to
actually been driving when I was in
college through that area just after the
eruption which is which was amazing to
see the number of cars come in with this
horrible ash all over it the it was
about a nine hour duration shot ash and
up 20 kilometers in the atmosphere but
it was also again like sin PR a side
blast first there was a collapse and
then a side blast that wiped out most of
the forests just off to the to the east
of it okay
and lately and about from 2004 to 2008
activity has started again there is a
new dome built inside this crater much
like the dome that we hiked up on some
Montpelier just just about a month ago
or so so in summary to close out okay
first of all message I want to get
across is that geological activity is
really due to that the fact that the
earth is just cooling to space but it
winds up that cooling drives plate
tectonics which explains a lot of what
we understand about these disasters okay
that these most of these things occur on
plate tectonic boundaries
okay the nature of those boundaries
tells us a lot first where these things
occur and what types of disasters
they're likely to be and the big message
is that where there is subduction where
there are the coal stuff diving into the
mantle is actually where there are the
biggest earthquakes and the biggest
volcanoes and at that I will stop thank
you very much